hey guys dr. Berg here in this video we're going
to talk about insomnia depression and anxiety
okay there's a lot of confusion out there when
you look up depression you know psychiatrists
labeled depression causes insomnia okay and it
leads to anxiety and anxiety leads to depression
I mean it's just like one big ball of confusion
and of course we have a drug for you but let's
just take a look at what the difference is
between depression and anxiety depression is
the blues it's apathy you lose hope you don't care
anymore you're feeling down okay anxiety is worry
fear panic always nervous always thinking always
solving problems okay so that's the difference
between those two now I believe that insomnia
if you were to correct that you would see huge
changes so let's talk about what would cause
insomnia normally light it's supposed to wake
you up in the morning right and then when it gets
dark it's supposed to help you go to sleep and
this is all controlled by the circadian rhythms
are called and there's hormones involved you have
a clock a mini clock in your brain called the
super chiming nuclei and it's triggered by light
and dark okay so vitamin D for example when you're
out in the sunlight you get more vitamin D vitamin
D is really good as an anti depression type thing
and that's probably why the mint a winter's month
people get depressed because they don't have
enough vitamin D so that's one thing but how many
people sit inside all day watching their computers
like sitting all day long watching YouTube videos
I don't know if you know anyone maybe you of
course myself do I watch a lot of YouTube but
vitamin D will actually light triggers vitamin
D absorption through the skin but you got to be
outside and be exposed to it now when it gets dark
out which is interesting because you may be being
you're inside the room and it's all it's light
until you finally turn the light off so there's no
chance for the darkness to start stimulating the
hormone called melatonin so melatonin is if you
take it as a supplement it'll start to create some
tiredness because it turns into serotonin which is
the sleep hormone which is also a mood hormone
too so we have these this is hormonal shift okay
and then even in the morning there's another
hormone that kicks in that wakes you up it's
called noradrenaline it's similar to adrenaline
okay so we also have other things that can help
you sleep as well and that would be making sure
that you have enough be one if you deficient in
vitamin b1 you're going to be very restless you're
going to have a lot of nervous tension you're not
going to be able to wind down easily at night
you're going to be excessively thinking all the
time so that's that nervous energy that just that
low tolerance to stress it's just it's bate it's
basically related to the adrenals when you're
Drina gland is overactive you deplete b1 and
so it's kind of like you have this slider fight
nervous stress state that you are stuck in okay
so we need b1 the other thing that will deplete
b1 is alcohol and sugar refined carbohydrates and
also having gastric bypass here you are trying
to lose weight and you get a gastric bypass
and now you can absorb b1 that well so and then
that creates sleeping problems and more weight
gain you name it the minerals that help sleep are
magnesium and potassium and calcium so those are
three minerals that are relaxing they're calming
on the nervous system where you get these three
minerals from vegetables okay that's the main
source so you want to consume enough vegetables
the other thing that can affect your sleep
especially urinating all night long would be
having insulin resistance it's like a pre-diabetic
or even being a diabetic so what we want to do is
you want to correct it I put some links down below
if you have a blood sugar issue I don't want to go
into that right now but if you have that problem
that could actually seriously affect your sleep
hypoglycemia that's a low blood sugar very similar
to insulin resistance but what happens is that you
might find in the middle of night you just wake
up for no reason that's because the blood sugars
and it stimulates adrenaline that kicks in the
blood sugars again it starts to kind of come
back up so try to sleep if you have adrenaline
running through your bloodstream it's not going
to work and then lastly digestion digestion can
seriously affect your quality of sleep especially
at night let's say you have dinner and you sit in
front of the TV and you start grazing and start
snacking all the time you go to bed you're stuffed
you think that might affect your sleep it does so
we really want to make sure that you after dinner
you don't eat anything okay until you go to bed
that's going to actually greatly help the quality
of sleep the other thing is getting outside to get
some space you're inside all day long you need to
get us I go for a walk walking is the best thing
to chill out the adrenal gland which is involved
in stress and many sleep issues okay so that's
pretty much that will help you with insomnia
now if you have specific symptom depression
the key vibe the two vitamins that are involved in
depressed states are vitamin b3 and b12 so what I
do I like to recommend nutritional yeast take it
in a tablespoon a couple times a day because you
need probably more but that's those two are really
good to actually pull some another depression but
it also could be that your digestive system is
so far off you can't absorb the vitamins let's
say you have leaky gut or a damage or IBS or
or constipation those things could affect the
absorption or if you drink a lot of alcohol that
could be it right there but the B vitamins are
key in depression or you could have a hypothyroid
issue which is deeper it's it's a bile deficiency
gall bladder or liver or high estrogen from the
cycle to cause a hypothyroid issue I have some
videos on that I'll put a link down below but I
would honestly first start trying to work on your
sleep to get to sleep better because you'll be
surprised you may have such chronic fatigue that
it feels like you're depressed it's almost the
same sensation so I would go aft get some energy
and then see if you're really depressed okay
now then you have anxiety that's usually adrenal
the adrenal controls the adaptation of stress
and to the body so your body is adapting to a
stress state but when the adrenal gland is being
stimulated too often it can almost kind of put you
in a state of stress mode 24/7 almost like you're
kind of in a flight or fight and it could come
from many reasons let's say you're drinking a lot
of coffee you had a history in college you drank a
lot of coffee like myself math the dosages of high
quality Cuban coffee that was me and I would just
drink tons of it and then all of a sudden I just
started crashing and burning so you have things
that stimulates the adrenal caffeine will do it
and then also just being in a stress State being
in a bad relationship having a trauma emotional
stress watching too much of the news will do
it unfortunately in the news is like constant
speculation like always recycled the same story
recycled what if this happens what if that happens
so you really have to control what you watch what
you're exposed to because if you sit there and
watch TV and then try to go to bed it's going to
be on your mind so I would recommend turning that
thing off and reading a book the other thing that
what I use for the adrenal is I use an adrenal
night formula and my massage will be for bed
every night I'll put a link down below for more
information on that now for anxiety it's b1 b1
deficiency will handle most types of anxiety so
that's a nutritional yeast again so you could just
take nutrition aleast and kill two birds with one
stone it also is going to help you sleep as well
especially that except you know that winding down
at night potassium is really important and anxiety
as well because it's a physiological tranquilizer
it's a calming mineral it works similar to
magnesium but it calms the pulse rate down its
way that you know your potassium addition is
your pulse rate really high put your head on the
pillow and you feel that pounding boom boom boom
boom your potassium deficient and you just can't
wind down easily if you have enough potassium
you will be able to sleep and your muscles will be
relaxed and then just avoid you know like I talked
about on the videos you have to take a long list
of all the people that are stressing you out and
just avoid them because I have you know I've been
in practice for a long time and I keep running the
same situation where someone is you start digging
deep into their environment and they're loaded
with just people that are constantly stressing
about I'm like why don't you do something about it
why can't well you know find another relationship
or something because it's just killing it so those
are some things now nutritionally I think
it's going to help you and I think change
of environment going for a long walks exercise
is going to really help you but I want to just
kind of mention this this thing that's happening
recently there's a lot of people put on psych
drugs Prozac medication okay now what's going to
happen in the next couple years you're going to
see a shift to another form of therapy which is
pretty scary for depression and even anxiety and
they're going to use it under this classification
of treatment resistance so if the drugs don't work
they do the next thing okay and it's called deep
brain stimulation and I'm not kidding you that's
actually used right now in a lot of hospitals
even there's four children's centers around bottom
Washington DC right now that use this therapy on
kids I'm not kidding I'll put some links down I
don't want to depress you any more but I want
to increase your awareness and what's going to
happen what some doctors are shifting to some are
going away from drugs into even ECT electric shock
therapy for depression unfortunately that's what's
going to be happening so I want your awareness to
be very high and if you see this definitely object
to it because when they do deep brain stimulation
there's two parts to it they basically lock up
your skull and the first part is they drill two
holes in your skull I'm not kidding and then
what they do is they put two wires into the
brain okay so that's part one part two is they
put a pacemaker type mechanism in your chest and
then they can control it remotely and they run
electricity to your brain and there's actually
hardly any Studies on this okay now there's a
builder trying to pass right now called the 21st
century cure act and basically it's calling to
skip the scientifically sound and safety testing
for new medical devices okay so they want to slip
this in hopefully they won't get it passed they
flip this in with the FDA and now they don't have
to do testing to even see it is safe and use it
even on children I'm not kidding watch the links
down below and now some of you who don't even want
to know about this but I think it's good to know
about it because they're really pushing this big
time there's even a facility in New York right
now but they're experimenting on kids and it's
just it's sickening so they're going from drugs
now to this electrical device with actually no
studies incredible and it's because the drugs
don't work right so what I want you to do is
get the word out about natural things that you can
do because what's happening now is there's just no
differentiation between cause and effect like they
don't medical profession especially psychiatrists
don't look at the cause and effect relationship
they get it confused they say well depression
causes insomnia insomnia causes depression
they don't really look at cause and effect
okay so check out some links below thank you so
much for watching and I'll see in the next video